[Música]
bienvenidos a en 5 minutos con hoy nos
acompaña
miravet coordinadora de documentación y
seguimiento de casos en artículo 19 una
organización independiente que promueve
y defiende el avance de los derechos de
la libertad de expresión gracias señora
miravete por esta comunicación en méxico
varios colectivos feministas han
protestado recientemente para condenar
no sólo las violentas represiones
policiales en cancún sino el asesinato
de alrededor de una docena de mujeres
por razones de género en lo que va
corrido del año de acuerdo con reportes
de la fiscalía de quintana roo como
analizan este caso de la represión de
las protestas feministas en cancún que
garantías y de derechos tienen las
mujeres actualmente en mexico
hola qué tal pues muchas gracias por la
invitación y saludos al auditorio
efectivamente como mencionan lo ocurrido
en cancún quintana roo
es un acto a nivel nacional bastante
preocupante bueno e incluso
internacional
consideramos las organizaciones de la
sociedad y hemos visto como la violencia
de género se presenta cada vez más
seguido y en este sentido también las
represiones a las protestas feministas
que se llevan en el país para exigir un
alto a esta violencia
pues también se han visto reprimidas no
sólo en cancún quintana roo las hemos
visto en otros estados
de méxico y guanajuato como en la ciudad
de méxico sin embargo tenía muchos años
en este sexenio no había ocurrido que
nos tocara documentar un caso de
violencia contra una protesta pacífica
de tal magnitud
además de los feminicidios los
asesinatos de periodistas en méxico no
dan tregua siendo uno de los países con
más peligro para ejercer el periodismo
en el mundo qué pasa con la libertad de
expresión en mexico
bueno pues como como ocurrió en el caso
de la protesta los periodistas fueron
agredidos aquí en méxico eso ocurre
según nuestros últimos reportes en
promedio cada 10 16 horas se abre de dos
periodistas sobre todo estas últimas
semanas han sido bastante complicadas en
menos de diez días se registraron tres
asesinatos de periodistas seguimos el
proceso para ver si estos asesinatos
pudieran estar vinculados por su labor
periodística
sin embargo por ejemplo en el caso de
israel
en guanajuato que fue el último
asesinato que se registró la semana
pasada
ahí sí fue muy claro que la agresión
estaba vinculada con su labor
periodística no por lo menos en méxico
vemos que no existen garantías para
ejercer la libertad de expresión y vemos
con mucha preocupación que la violencia
contra la prensa se registra en
múltiples maneras desde
pues bloqueos informativos
a actos de intimidación estiramiento
campañas de desprestigio también hemos
estado registrando acosos judiciales
y pues ahora cada vez más seguido
estamos viendo también asesinatos e
incluso estas semanas están registrado
también desapariciones portadas de todo
este elsa este sábado en la noche de
manera muy reciente
un periodista del sinaloa mazatlán fue
víctima de desaparición por parte de un
grupo armado asilo por nada mente y
gracias a la presión fue localizado con
vida y ya mira vete disculpa te pido o
brevedad pues nos queda menos de un
minuto cuál es el papel del gobierno
mexicano en esta crisis de libertad de
expresión
pues tristemente no hemos visto en el
estado mexicano voluntad para realmente
garantizar el ejercicio de la libertad
de expresión aquí en méxico por lo menos
desde el presidente de la república te
habla de que existe libertad de
expresión y de que éste garantiza
plenamente a diferencia de otros
gobiernos por eso todavía no lo hemos
visto las sociedades de las las
organizaciones de la sociedad civil
hemos insistido en que es necesario una
política pública general de protección y
todavía no se ha llevado a cabo seguimos
insistiendo con esta idea miravete
muchas gracias por esta comunicación y
por tu análisis se les corre una hora de
documentación y seguimiento de casos y
en artículo 19 ya ustedes muchas gracias
por su compañía los invitamos a seguir
con más mucho más aquí en france 24
[Música]